now maybe repeat what I said before just
in case you'd forgotten you bid like
I've gone too deep into the question
when you have a look at something like
this right the further you go in
mathematics the more that the problems
you encounter it's okay it's right I can
see the conversation you're in I'm like
I don't know stop that but I do want to
stop it the further you go into
mathematics the more you encounter
problems that can be solved in many many
different ways many different ways so
when you look at this
I can eyeball there's at least five
different ways I can go through this and
part of like be a good mathematician is
knowing which is the best way to go not
just that I can do it many ways but oh I
think this might be a more helpful
method rather another one for example
hopefully so if you noticed or you know
to notice that if you want to factorize
this thing right you can you're gonna
come up with this is a cubic you know
it's something times something else
times something else okay
now hopefully one of the things you
remember is that when you're coming up
with these things you don't have to
guess randomly for instance this number
down the end here it gives you some
enormous clues as to what your three
things are going to be right if you can
know in advance that they're giving you
something which you can actually
factorize you're probably gonna get some
nice whole numbers here not always but
usually so a really good guess as to
something which might end up giving you
a factor is something that is a multiple
or division y5 fracked you see that yeah
so you can get numbers out of that right
however however when you start to put
things in write one of the problems with
this is it sort of requires you to use
some polynomial long division polynomial
long division is not bad that's why we
taught it to you but as the name
suggests it's long right is there some
way that we can avoid as as a problem
solver I'm looking at this thinking I
know I can do that but do I have some
other alternatives and the answer is I
do because of this information right in
here right now this is provided to you
to give you a nudge right you don't need
this piece of information strictly
speaking to solve it but because you do
you can go about it using some of the
knowledge you have we
of calculus right it's got a double root
so if you picture this right what does a
cubic look like in your brain if you
could picture what does it look like you
sort of have like this Wiggly thing
happening right so for example you might
have something like this now just have a
look at this particular polynomial I've
drawn does this have a double root no it
does not it has three roots one two
three and each one is a single root very
good so this is not what my polynomial
looks like my polynomial might look
something more like this see this guy
here right it's the same kind of shape
because of where I've moved it up and
down it's got a double root right there
and then you've got this other guy over
here that's a single root okay now I
should point out one of the reasons why
this is important to us is it means I
can use calculus on this original
function not all cubics have stationary
points you don't see those two over
there see how they've got two stationary
points each here's one here's one here's
one here's one down here okay if you
were to exempt for example graph X cubed
plus X right probably when you look at
that you're like I have no idea what
that looks like off the top of my head
but in fact this does not have any
stationary points and we can really
easily see how right how would you find
a stationary point where do stationary
points like these guys how do you find
them it's when it's when the derivative
so in the derivative equals what zero
because that gives you that our
horizontal tangent right now in this
case the derivative is very easy to find
right do I on DX can you help me out
what would you do with this 3x squared
plus one very good so if you wanted to
find some stationary points you'd say
well let's just find out when that thing
down the bottom that derivative when is
it equal to zero in other words when is
this true question mark now wonder if
some of you can look at that and see why
it immediately gives you some problems
have a look what would you do to start
solving this guy
yeah let's subtract one from both sides
so that gives me this and then what yeah
I might divide by three to make wrasses
point a bit more obvious I get this my
[ __ ] third having you like wait a
second this is a bit of a problem right
I'm not supposed to be able to take
square roots of negative numbers and in
this context you can go ahead and graph
it in desmos if you like from memory it
looks something like this
so it never does this turning thing it
does kind of wobble a little bit but it
does not ever turn around and change
direction okay but the wonderful thing
about this because they've told you it
has a double root you can know with
certainty there will be a stationary
point right so I need to work with this
thing and get its derivative let's do
this together P - okay I'm gonna go
ahead and I'm going to find the druvan
and then I'm gonna use it along with
this knowledge that there is a double
root okay can someone help me out this
is our function first thing that
differentiate is this guy here which
gives you what you're actually your
topic very good 3x squared next term
belong plus 18x and in the last it's one
that I really need to worry about -21
why is that the last term I need to
worry about it is negative but why not
worry about this guy it's just a
constant so when I differentiate it's
gone okay it just changes where you are
up and down it doesn't change your slant
or your gradient so here's my derivative
okay
now can you what could this any easier
like it's it's fine that is the
derivative you differentiate it but can
I simplify it anymore yeah it's a factor
of three so let's just take that out to
the front that leaves me with x squared
plus 6x minus seven very good can you do
anything with this we can't write can we
factorize this water out what's how pair
of numbers
adds to this multiplies to that - seven
oh one or minus one and seven plus seven
X minus one and of course you could just
expand that to check it out so what I've
done is I've differentiated tired it up
a little bit now I have it in a
factorized form but how can I use this
think about all of this visual stuff
that we were talking about before what
can I say about this or from this say it
again where is this thank you so know
when is this zero you can see that the
derivative P - will be zero at two
particular values one from here and one
from here which ones are they negative
seven or positive one so I've got two
stationary points two stationary points
these correspond to like this guy and
this guy right I mean that's just that
example these are not the actual values
right but I know that one of these one
of these will be the double root can you
see that one of them has to be how do I
work out which one is the double root I
can substitute them in right I could do
even better than that though I can do
better than that if I substitute in to
here I can know in advance I'm looking
for a particular value right one of
these is a double root so therefore it
should give me a factor of the original
polynomial that was that's the whole
point after all right so the factor
theorem tells me once I find the correct
one and substitute in what should you
expect to get you should expect to get
zero can you go ahead this most of your
impairs what have you test out this guy
what do you test out that one you've got
to calculate it give it a go you go just
go ahead give it yeah I need to see you
actually do it because that's part of it
yeah very good you can see it right yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
3:43 I've just done enough times I
didn't intend to memorize it I just have
done a lot of us okay now hopefully what
you've gotten to is something like this
right by the way as you're doing your
notes can I just highlight this line
here let me just put a big green thing
about it you know mrs. Lee's and I have
highlighted this multiple times but
you're working is meant to every single
time no matter what kind of question is
solving you're working is meant to
produce an argument it's something I
should be able to look down this and say
oh I can follow your line of thought
right so rather than go from here
straight to evaluating some stuff did
you notice we talked for a while about
what our next step would be and why and
so our talking needs to be translated
into something on your page and that's
why in this light here I say oh I can
draw a conclusion about this derivative
based on what the original question said
this connection with the double root and
you should say that it's part of your
argument okay Russell I was hoping
someone would ask his questions so well
I didn't address this when we were
talking about it out loud but as some of
you might have liked wrestling I
certainly noticed I put this word either
here I've got an x equals negative 7 or
x equals 1 I've got stationary points
there right and then I've gone ahead and
said this double root that the original
question talked about it's got to be
either this or that now there are two
options right either/or and like it
could be both of them right but why do I
know from the original question from the
first line I wrote how do I know that
the double root can only occur at one of
them and not at both have a think there
can only be one double root but how do
you know I mean to say you know it has a
double root I could say I have a
whiteboard marker in my bag but I
actually have several and it's still
true how do you know they can only be
one Zacky what are you thinking so let's
have a look at this original polynomial
right the degree or the which is the
power of the leading term so you can
just say degree the degree is three that
tells you there's a maximum number of
roots in the whole polynomial what's the
maximum number it's equal to the degree
right if you want more route to ever
this polynomial excuse me that you need
to have a higher degree if there were
two double roots you'd have to have a
degree of four at a minimum you could
have degree of five or six or seven
right but here if there's a double root
the only other thing you can have is a
single root so one has to be double one
has to be well this is just a regular
stationary point somewhere else okay